If you create a sustainable city,
a city that has circular principles,
a city that engages with the environment,
you are creating a healthier population.
The problem here is we
haven't made that link
between circular design and livelihoods.
You know, the Ellen MacArthur
foundation talks about
this idea of circular economy pioneers.
A lot of the things that
I wanted to learn about,
nobody is teaching.
Or, they've only been teaching
it for the past five years.
It's all so new that in a way,
you couldn't have done it before.
- But then you leave the
footprints for people to follow.
- Exactly, you are creating that new path.
This is the reason why people like us
are interested in circular design.
It's not just for what it means now,
but for what it means in 50, 100 years.
- Yeah, now we have to
create that narrative,
which makes people appreciate that,
okay, sustainability
is very, very important
to be able to take care
of my children, my family,
even myself.
- Yeah.